tell my name is Dan Shechtman I am a
distinguished professor of the day not
in Haifa Israel I'm a laureate of Nobel
Prize in Chemistry 2011 for the
discovery of quasi periodic crystals
before that the definition of a crystal
was a crystal is a material in which
atoms are ordered and periodic period if
you want to understand periodicity look
at tiles on the floor if there are
squares then in engineering direction
that you point you see that the tile
repeats themselves exactly the same way
this is a two-dimensional
priority-setting other participe is more
complex it appears in nature in a more
complex way such as spirals that we find
in icons and shells of certain sea lives
so let's talk about quasi periodicity in
two dimension and the perfect example of
general styles and you can tile the
floor with pennilyn style you can do it
quasi periodically if you follow certain
matching boards and there will be no
gaps and everything will be fitted
properly so two-dimensional Penrose
3-dimensional or quasi periodic crystal
so the year was 1982 and after lunch I
put aluminum twenty-five percent
manganese into the microscope and
started to look at it when I first saw
the diffraction pattern with ten fold
rotation symmetry I said I looked at it
and said in Hebrew in hyukoh so it means
a mere a there ain't no such animal this
discovery was a paradigm shift in
calligraphy created a new definition of
what is a crystal so today
we have our many many crystal food we
have three-dimensional across the
political conscience of them in fact
it's quite surprising that there were
not discovered before
you
we all want to
that our food is safe but doing that can
be really hard looking for contaminants
in raw materials is tough the statistics
are stacked against us today we can only
test for pathogens individually one
sample at a time and that means hundreds
is not thousands of tests most of which
deliver a simple negative legal we
needed to think about this differently
that's why Mars and IBM join forces to
sequence the genomes of all the
organisms in the food supply chain
that's millions of organisms but big
data is what IBM is good at the DNA and
RNA sequences show you all the harmless
bacteria that are found in normal safe
food if we do the test and the
microorganisms are suddenly different
something's up the organisms have
changed because the environment has
changed it could be contaminated and not
only that this tells us things that we
never could have seen before like where
the food was grown how it was
transported and maybe even what happened
on route our approach to food safety
just got a lot smarter